S
INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT THAT
NEITHER CAN THE GUY AT 1600
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE.
JOINING ME A GREAT HISTORIAN IN
HIS OWN RIGHT.
FORMER DEPUTY WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
OF STAFF KARL ROVE.
HOW ARE WE BACK AT THIS SPOT
TODAY?
>> IN 2020 WE NOMINATED AND
ELECTED A PRESIDENT WHO WAS 78
YEARS OLD, AND ALREADY SUFFERING
SOME CHALLENGES AND THEY HAVE
ONLY GOTTEN WORSE.
AND YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE DIDN'T KNOW -- WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE EXPOSURE WE NORMALLY HAVE TO
CANDIDATES BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
AS A RESULT HE HID OUT IN HIS
BASEMENT.
HE DID INTERVIEWS WITH LOCAL
NEWS ANCHORS VIA ZOOM.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN WAS.
THERE IS A UTILITY TO HAVING AN
ACTUAL CAMPAIGN WHERE WE GET TO
TAKE THE MEASURE OF THE
CANDIDATE SEEKING THE HIGHEST
OFFICE IN THE LAND.
AND WE GOT WHAT WE GOT.
BRIAN: WHAT DO YOU THINK WE GOT?
DO WE HAVE A DEMOCRAT WHO WILL
TAKE A SENATE SEAT FROM A
CONSERVATIVE NAMED PAT TOOMEY?
>> I THINK THE FETTERMAN ISSUE
IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE WE ARE
SEEING IT PLAY OUT BEFORE THE
CAMPAIGN.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
PRIVATELY LOOKING AT THAT AND
SAYING DO I THINK THAT GUY IS
READY TO TAKE ON THIS TOUGH
CHALLENGE AND DO I HAVE
CONFIDENCE HE WILL BE ABLE TO
RECOVER AND DO A GOOD JOB FOR
ME.
IT WILL HAVE A DEEP IMPACT ON
PEOPLE'S VOTES, I THINK.
THAT'S WHY THE LAST 11 AND 12
DAYS OF THE CAMPAIGN WILL BE SO
CRITICAL.
I THINK PEOPLE WILL BE LOOKING
AT DR. OZ CLOSELY SAYING I HAVE
GOT SOME DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT
FETTERMAN.
DO I THINK OZ SHARES MY VALUES
AND WILL DO A GOOD JOB FOR ME.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY OZ
WINS.
BRIAN: THE INSIDER POLL IS THE
FIRST ONE I HAVE SEEN WITH
DR. OZ LEADING.
IN THE REARVIEW MIRROR OF THAT
ONE AND ONLY DEBATE.
YOU HEARD CHUCK SCHUMER CAUGHT
ON A HOT MIC SAYING WE WEREN'T
HURT THAT MUCH BY THAT DEBATE.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S DAMAGE
CONTROL?
>> I THINK HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL.
AND CHUCK SCHUMER WANTS TO HOLD
ON TO HIS ROLE AND PENNSYLVANIA
WILL PLAY A ROLE IN THAT.
I THINK IT WAS WISHFUL THINKING.
PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT THAT AND
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS.
AND I THINK THE JUDGMENT IS
GOING TEND TO BE AGAINST
FETTERMAN.
THIS WAS REALLY PROBLEMATIC.
WHY HE DID IT IS BEYOND ME.
THERE IS POLITICAL MALPRACTICE
ON BEHALF OF HIS HANDLERS.
BUT THEY PROPER HI DID THE
PEOPLE OF THE COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA A FAVOR BY PUTTING
HIM IN THE DEBATE.
BRIAN: AND THE COUNTRY.
TO THINK SOMEBODY WITH CLEAR
PROBLEMS HAS TO READ CLOSED
CAPTIONS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING TO HIM CAN DO
A JOB LIKE THAT?
IF YOU OR I HAD THAT PROBLEM WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO THIS WHAT
WE ARE DOING RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE ON THE
AIR.
EVEN THOUGH THE SYMPATHY WOULD
BE STRONG, I COULDN'T DO IT.
>> MEMBERS OF THE CONGRESS,
HOUSE AND SENATE HAVE HAD
SERIOUS ILLNESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEBILITATING.
SENATOR MARK KIRK HAD A SERIOUS
STROKE IN THE MIDDLE OF HIS
TERM.
BUT WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS THE VOTERS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO MAKE THE DECISION.
BUT IN THE CASE OF MARK KIRK HE
WAS NOT ABLE TO GET BACK TO
WHERE HE WAS BEFORE THE STROKE.
THIS HAPPENED TO FETTERMAN WHEN
HE WAS RUNNING.
IT TURNS OUT HE HAD A SERIOUS
HEALTH PROBLEM WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AND DIDN'T REVEAL IT.
HE HAD A FIB.
SO VOTERS WILL LOOK AT THAT IN
TOTALITY AND SAYING IT'S ONE
THING IF YOU ARE IN OFFICE, YOU
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION WHETHER
YOU CAN GET BACK OR NOT.
BUT YOU ARE ASKING US FOR A VOTE
FOR THE NEXT 6 YEARS.
SOME THEM WILL SAY WE HAVE
LITTLE OR NO CONFIDENCE YOU WILL
GET BACK TO 100%.
THE VOTERS ARE GOING TO TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION.
BRIAN: DO YOU BELIEVE THE SENATE
GOES TO THE REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS WHEN IT'S ALL SAID AND
DONE?
WE HAD A RUNOFF IN GEORGIA AFTER
NOVEMBER 8?
>> I THINK IT GOES TO THE
REPUBLICANS NARROWLY.
BUT IT WILL BE A VERY
INTERESTING NOT JUST NIGHT, BUT
POTENTIALLY SEVERAL DAYS AND
COULD BE A MONTH.
I SAY SEVERAL DAYS BECAUSE
WISCONSIN WHERE THERE IS A
CRITICAL RACE, RON JOHNSON AND
PENNSYLVANIA DON'T ALLOW LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO BEGIN
WORKING THE EARLY BALLOTS UNTIL
THE POLLS CLOSE UNLIKE A LOT OF
OTHER STATES.
IN TEXAS THEY CAN RUN THOSE
BALLOTS AS SOON AS THE POLLS
CLOSE AND THEY ARE REPORTED
EARLY.
BUT IT MAY BE SEVERAL DAYS IN A
CLOSE RACE BEFORE WE KNOW WHO
WINS IN PENNSYLVANIA OR
WISCONSIN.
I FEEL PRETTY GOOD ABOUT
WISCONSIN THAT WE'LL KNOW
RELATIVELY EARLY.
BUT I THINK IT'S UNCONSTRUCTIVE
TO THE PEOPLE'S CONTINUING
CONFIDEN